[Music]
[Applause]
question i want to make way for
peter king joining us on loan from nbc
sports and the columnist football
morning
in america peter thanks for joining us
uh let me start with uh russell wilson
and what you think he was trying to say
yesterday and did he get his message
across
well dan russell wilson uh never
the fact that he spoke out and mentioned
how often he's been sacked uh
and he's mentioned those kind of things
to you he never talks about that ever
ali all he talks about is i love my
offensive line
they're playing their rear ends off
they're they're they're great i love
them
the fact that he mentions that it's not
to say
you guys stink it's to tell
uh the front office uh john schneider
pete carroll
um i want to be protected better
it's not right it's not fair that i'm
not protected better
that's his view now i'm sure that pete
and i'm sure that the coaches and john
schneider might look at the tape and say
you hold on to the ball too long yeah
you know you t you you take too many
desperado chances
throw the ball in the first row of the
bleachers sometimes
and uh or or throw it more often there
but dan
this to me was about russell wilson
saying
going to the super bowl on sunday night
i saw
one shot of him it's funny when you're
at the super bowl which i was
you don't watch tv so you don't see what
anybody sees
i did see one shot of him and i'll tell
you what he just
looked like he ate a turd sandwich i
mean
he was totally this one shot
he's just miserable yeah and he doesn't
he doesn't want to be at the super bowl
unless he's playing in it
and and i just i i just think this is a
guy
who's at the midpoint of his career and
looks at tom brady and says
man why can't i go into a place where
the offense is set up for the next two
or three years
to maybe win multiple super bowls we're
not and again
i'm totally putting words in russell
wilson's mouth i haven't talked to him
i'm just saying what i heard when he
talked to you yesterday
yeah i wonder what seattle does i wonder
what
front office or pete carroll have to say
whenever they get in front of the media
it's a good question i don't know the
answer to it i do
know that you know look i think
john schneider is a great general
manager not a good one he's great
um but he hasn't drafted great on the
offensive line
he hasn't solved the offensive line long
term
you know it's just like belichick and
receivers john and an
offensive line it just really hasn't
worked and
and again i'm sure that there are issues
that i don't understand okay because i'm
not there every day
but you know i do think now especially
they got a new offensive coordinator
shane waldron you know he hasn't called
plays i don't
think before the best of my knowledge
and so
you know they're counting on sort of the
sean mcvay
way to work and i i don't i don't know
if it's going to work
we'll see but i sensed
dissatisfaction in russell wilson that i
haven't heard before
the eagles situation is a hot mess like
this is a soap opera a local soap opera
there pete because i
get the feeling the colts and uh
the bears might be interested but not at
the asking price and it feels like the
eagles are asking too much for carson
wentz and now you've made carson walk
the plank
he doesn't want to go back where he's
not appreciated now where does he go and
if you're the colts or the bears what do
you really want to offer a guy that you
also have to take his salary on as well
i can tell you that that there are
people
in the nfl there are uh
of the 31 other teams without being too
specific
that are very interested in carson wentz
but very interested at a reasonable
price okay and what i mean by that is
nobody really knows
what's reasonable i quoted uh uh
a team official this week that after
matthew st
after matthew stafford what is a logical
price
right now for a quarterback i we don't
know
i mean two ones and a three even though
the ones are in the future
um but i i also think this dan about
carson wentz
with matthew stafford you sort of know
what you're getting yeah
with carson wentz you have no idea what
you're getting in 2017
he was a top five quarterback in the nfl
in 2018 and 19
pretty good 2020 an abject disaster
charges that he's unco
not he doesn't like to be coached i'm
not saying uncoachable
it didn't take coaching very well you
know was at odds with doug peterson
was you know and all this stuff he
hasn't done enough in this
game to be to be difficult to work with
he just hasn't so if you're a team right
now
what do you want to pay for him really
what do you want to pay
for carson wentz if i were the if i were
the colts or the bears
bears have the 20th pick colts have the
21st pick
i'd pay that but if you want to get much
beyond that
i'd say no thanks i'll draft somebody
and take my chances but
is there more upside with carson wentz
or more downside
with carson wentz if you pick him up i
you have to believe if you're frank
reich
the last time frank wright was in the
building every day with carson wentz
he was pure gold you know as a player
before he got hurt
and being coached and everything carson
i think frank wright would love to coach
carson once again
he told me on my podcast about a month
ago i love
carson wentz you know and so i i think
he would love
and believe i'm not don't get into the
the whole
uh tampering thing cause he's you know
he said look
i can't say anything about it but all i
can say is having been with him i love
the guy
and i'll always love him but i do think
dan
even though he loves him and i i've
certainly not talked to him about this
even though he loves him
he's got to have some skepticism
okay about what exactly
he's doing talking to peter king
nbcsports.com columnist football morning
in america all quiet on the desean
watson front pete is that good or bad
you know dan i just think that uh
nick casario does not want
possibly probably the biggest decision
he ever makes if he decides to trade him
uh you know i i as i wrote a week or so
ago i don't mean to be morbid but you
don't want the second paragraph in your
obit
to be here's the guy who traded desean
watson
you know it's you just you want your
professional reputation
to be that he fought like hell to to
keep desean watson
it worked and they were a good franchise
that's what nick casario wants
and i'm sure that's what david culley
wants but this is an organization that
is adrift
totally absolutely adrift and when i
look at it dan
i think i mean if i had to guess right
now i don't think desean watson's going
to be unless there's a civil war
i don't think he's going to be traded by
the draft i think they're going to say
you play with us or you don't play
yeah i'm with you i i feel like we're in
the minority that desean
you know it's wishful reporting like we
we want him to move someplace else it
gives us something to talk about but i
think
if you're the texans unless somebody
blows you away you just say no
you're our quarterback we gave you this
extension
and uh you know what we we're gonna ride
with you
die with you uh let me leave you with
this because we of course have to
somehow work the cowboys in this
with the hype video that didn't include
dak prescott
peter what do you make of this
i don't know i'm 63 years old dan i
don't
i don't care you know i mean i guess i
should care
people look for clues dan you know what
when i first got in this business and
covered the cincinnati bengals you know
what i did in the off season
you know for a while anyway i covered
college basketball
i covered uh the reds as a backup beat
writer
and everything like that i didn't i
wasn't bengals 24
7. you know and and you know
the problem is now you've got newspapers
and websites with three beat people 365
days a year
studying looking for signs doing all
this stuff
and sometimes i'm sure that deep down
there's some meeting like the cowboys
don't know
absolutely for sure if dak prescott's
going to be on the team
i i guess that would be uh the
explanation
but honestly i think any thought that
dak prescott is not going to be on the
team
seems utterly preposterous he's the most
popular athlete right now
in the state of texas and i can't
imagine
i can't imagine that the cowboys
would uh be actively considering
not bringing him back even if it's on
that onerous second franchise tag
uh drew brees set to join you guys on uh
football night in america nbc
sports uh do you know anything about
i'll be the last one to know you'll
you'll have him on the show and he'll
say i'm announcing it but i dan i
i i think it's there's no way he's
playing next year you look at
you know jay glazer uh for him to say
something like that
um you know the the the un
it isn't a dirty little secret but i
mean he knows the saints
uh like you know the dayton flyers i
mean like he knows him
a lot and for him to say that that it's
this is his last game it's his last game
so in my
opinion i think they're just waiting for
the right time to really celebrate the
life and times of drew brees
and my feeling is he's probably going to
be on the nbc set
you know in august or september but you
know that's just my gut feeling what do
you expect to happen to the chiefs in
the offseason
um well i think
one of the things if if if i were them
one of the things i would really try to
do is pay a little bit more attention
to the offensive line because it looks
like
they were too and look you could say
this about a lot of teams
but they were two injuries away from
absolute disaster
so they've got to backstop their line i
think you'll see andy reid who
always pays attention to both lines
both in free agency in the draft i bet
on the first two days of the draft they
draft two tackles
that's just my gut feeling uh andy will
pay attention to this offensive line and
well he should my guess
is that sami watkins probably won't be
back
but the rest of the team i think mostly
is uh is going to be back intact did you
vote on the super bowl mvp
i did i voted for brady um was there any
consideration given to anybody else
definitely so at the start of the fourth
quarter i wasn't voting for brady
i was gonna vote for shaq barrett if the
game was three quarters long
and then in the fourth quarter it got
all
uh cloudy because here comes in
dominican sue making two or three big
plays
here comes the rest of their defense
devin white all over the field
my second choice i voted for brady we
had to vote with four minutes left in
the fourth quarter we could change
but we had to vote with four minutes
left in the fourth quarter
i voted for brady but at the end at the
very end i thought very hard about devon
white and then
you know he had that late interception i
have some regrets but not a lot
i mean tom brady was efficient and plus
here's what it also is dan tom brady
think about his value to this team
why did they really win the super bowl
why because tom brady came
tom brady remade the mental makeup of
that team
tom brady uh coached players
all through the season and you know tom
brady also brought the kind of
unselfishness
bruce arians talked to me about it after
the game rob gronkowski never once i
mean he had a game where he had zero
uh catches hey rob you okay yeah coach
i'm good i'm good
you know and so he brought that ethos
forget what the numbers are forget what
the stats are when devin white in
in december was complaining about not
making the pro bowl he said hey d
you know we're in this for a bigger bowl
you know and so
like shut up about your pro bowl who
cares
so i i have i'm not i don't feel bad
about
voting for him at all it was very close
the defense
probably was more significant in this
one game but
who on the defense you know we're gonna
make a hype video for you pete
okay yeah i'll take it yeah and you know
you've gotta
if you do make a hype video for me just
make sure you say i'm 63 years
old and i don't care about that stuff
please do that
thank you pete good to talk to you again
all right dan you take care that's peter
king nbcsports.com columnist and
football morning in america